BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT.  THEY ARE
LIVING ON THE EDGE.
>> THEY
FROM DALLAS IT IS GETTING TO THE
ANAHEIM DEFENSE AND
RADULOV WORKS THE TOP OF THE
ZONE.
INSTINCT FOR RYAN SUTER.
IT'S A PLAY WHERE THE PUCK IS TG
TO DO WITH ME, BUT HE'S QUITE
HAPPY TO STAY IN DALLAS ONEN THE
PAIVE PAVELSKI WAS ROBBED
REPEATEDLY BY JOHN CLEARS.
ANDRE SEKERA WINDS IT BACK
AROUND THE BOARDS HE WAS A
FOWL.
CAM TRYING TO SPREAD THE LINEJAE
BOARDS, GIBSON MADE IS
SUCH A, SUCH THE LINE
BETWEEN SEGUE SEGUIN,
FACE-OFF WINS NOT
USUAUA NET.
>> SIMON SKATES WITH HIM LONG Y.
SHATTENKIRK WAITS FOR CENTER FA.
PAVELSKI CURLSHEISKANEN JUST POT
HE?
>> HE'S SOF THE SKATES
OF FAKSA.
STICK OF
JAMIE DRYSDALE.
AND MUCH
AROUND THE DEFENDER TO GET INTO
THE SHOOTING LANE.
NOW TERRY KEEPS IT, HERES.
TROY TERRYFORMER THIRD OVERALL S
THE LINE FOR ROBERTSON.
HIS SHOT BLOCKED.
AND CURLINGFINAL MINUTE 15 OFVEE
PERSONNEL AS HINTZ AND ROBERTSON
ARE JOINED BY HEISKANEN TOF
THE ICE TROYWO
ON ONE FOR THE DUCKS.
>> ZEGRAS, LIKE HE'S GOT IT
GLUED TO HI